Anthony esslyn is a professor of English
at Thomas More College of Liberal Arts
beginning this fall he's lately left
Providence College for a reason I'm
going to state
yes his bachelor's degree from Princeton
University and his PhD in Renaissance
English literature from the University
of North Carolina did you go there John
John Somerville so there must be
something going on there he's the senior
editor I didn't say whether it was good
or not he's the senior editor for
touchstone he's a regular contributor to
crisis magazine he's the author of a lot
of books many of them very much admired
here a self-help book is 10 ways to
destroy the imagination of your child
and I bet that one didn't sell very well
because knowledge of how to do that
seems to be very widespread
he's written on Lucretius and Dante he's
written some beautiful things I have
been reading them for four or five
months now it's not important about him
except for something it reveals about
him
that the forces of enforced diversity
took after him at Providence College all
he did was talk about God nature and
truth didn't write it say a negative
thing but anybody that I can find and it
got free man as it is everywhere where I
went to get much of my education in
Claremont a friend of mine has been
barred from getting into a beautiful
place after which we have designed our
Cyril Center up there because people can
go in there and have dinner and talk and
argue all night long it's awesome and
eight deep angry people
barring entry so the lecture could not
be head and there's a YouTube video of
an old friend of mine
Tony Foucault Laura a chemistry
professor there
the nicest guy you will ever meet and
he's trying to get through in these
hands stop them and they won't move and
nothing has been done about that what
our speaker did was right lovely and
charitable things about that and I'm
going to paraphrase one of them I was
going to quote it but I thought no it's
so pretty he might say to himself he
wrote that he never really cared very
much about that diversity or his own
identity he didn't really know that he
had one he said by the grace of God he
was born a Roman Catholic and a fan of
the st. Louis Cardinals and they I'm
that too and the diversity thing he
discovered that there were people he
wanted to know about Dante long time ago
Dante spoke a different tongue so he
decided to learn the tongue he decided
to learn geography in the history of the
place where Dante lived in other words
he went there he went there without
leaving his room it took time extremely
rewarding time he had to give him
himself to it he had to forget about
himself he had to go confront something
a long time ago that's at a peak and
very great and if you do that you'll
want to do it again and the next time we
do it with somebody else you'll find out
that to somebody else thinks a different
thing and you'll go to a different place
and you'll learn a different language
and you'll study a different geography
and then you'll know that greatness is
something other than just agreement
about everything and once you know that
then you'll be puzzled by these things
that are going on right now
and you'll see the implication that if
these things that are going on right now
are to continue then this college cannot
continue because that's not what is for
so that is with very great pride that we
have here a man of the hour
Anthony Aslan Thank You president Donna
I wish I could speak for myself as well
as he has thank you
distinguished faculty and parents
kinfolk friends graduates I'm honored
and delighted to be here and on a lovely
day too
sun is shining I heard mockingbirds on
my way out here and the air bringing
suggestions of summer even to Michigan
all the way to Traverse City CACI I'm
showing my age here because when I was
in grade school
we still had geography we didn't it had
not been folded into that thing called
social studies so we made maps rather
than illiterate and ill-tempered posters
for the March for niceness so as I said
this auspicious moment my thoughts
naturally turned to poetry I am after
all an English professor and I think of
Satan in Paradise Lost for anybody here
from the University of Michigan yes
Paradise Lost is an epic poem by
by John Milton on the fall of man uh
does anybody here from Michigan State
yes a poem is poem is a form of art
using words and sounds as their basic
stuff and if we were at a Catholic
school I've asked if there were any
Jesuits because I'd have to identify
Satan for so so Satan has made his way
directly toward the new created world
and man they're placed with purpose - si
it's him by force he can destroy or
worse by some fault guile pervert that's
the new created world that is not the
United States but I think in life there
might be an analogy to draw there it is
the physical universe in all its glory
he's going to it not for any good he can
gain from it but merely to seduce man to
his loss where Satan says only in
destroying I find ease to my relentless
thoughts now to my mind Milton among
English authors is second only to
Shakespeare for his penetration into the
heart and all of its tangled thickets
and dark and musty corners and there is
a heart that we can talk about there is
a thing human nature has not changed
right so we find Satan at the beginning
of book 4 of Paradise Lost not rejoicing
in his speed even though he appears to
have eluded detection nor with cause to
boast for the evil he must face is not
just a punishment applied to him from
without it is the collapse of being that
he has brought on himself from within
and says Milton horror and doubt
distract his troubled thoughts and from
the bottom stir the hell within him for
within him hell he brings
and round about him nor from hell one
step no more than from himself can fly
by change of place that is remarkable
speech that follows Satan you understand
is Satan when he is around other Souls
whether they are the unfallen angels or
his fellows in crime the Devils whenever
that is the case he has to play the
politician and I used the word in its
scornful sense he had he cannot admit
the truth he can only be a rhetorician
but temporarily he's not as he believes
not within sight or hearing of any other
soul and then he cries for us a cry of
existential ruin says Satan which way
shall I fly infinite wrath or infinite
despair which way I fly is Hell myself
and hell and in the lowest deep lower
deep still threatening to devour me
opens wide to which the hell I suffer
seems a heaven now I know that there are
some people here who ask me I would be
asking to at this point why is this man
because beginning his commencement
speech by speaking about Satan after all
if you had done as most colleges do you
have it you would have invited and by
the way I owe a debt of gratitude to the
to the students at Hillsdale College I I
have heard that I was their choice but
I'm delighted and honored most students
will pick a celebrity or a political
hack I have not a celebrity at least my
bankbook shows that and the Lord has
saved me from being a political hack
mainly by giving me an IQ above 90
I'm not responsible for that I simply
was born that way
why is he speaking about Satan and I
reply that I do so because almost every
other speaker at commencement in this
nation the celebrities and political
hacks will be speaking about Satan only
they don't know that they are doing that
I'm giving you the prime example of
someone who has in their minds okay
commenced he's left the faculty Conclave
of pandemonium stridden boldly through
the gates and their security yards named
sin and death flown over the vast
security which is a summer between your
senior year in your first job and made
his way to the world to do what
everybody else from Fairbanks to Miami
will be recommending that you do and
that is to change it to change the world
to make the world a better place not to
love what is beautiful in the world to
love the world and to defend what is
good and right and Noble but to change
it because you don't actually love it
you don't cherish it we can call Satan
the first and the essential political
activists not the essential person who
is active in the community but an
activist now I'm being half facetious
here as befits the occasion half
facetious the activists is prone to
forget something and it is what Satan
himself confesses when no one is around
to hear it wherever I go the world will
be a fallen one not because of this or
that political system though some are
much better than others it will be a
fallen world
because I am in it I bear my sins and my
frailty and my ignorance with me and
they are considerable even the epicurean
Lucretia
recognize this he said we flee ourselves
whom we can never flee men are not bad
because they live under a monarchy
monarchies tend to be bad because
monarchs are men men are not bad in the
first instance because they live in a
socialist state socialist state is bad
because men run it and because it does
violence even to that part of the nature
of man that is not falling socialist
state I believe makes good men poor and
bad men worse so I'm not saying that one
set of laws is as good or bad as another
at Overlea that's nonsense but I'm
suspicious as my buddy Shakespeare was
of movers and shakers for the sake of
moving and shaking those who think of
the world as Richard a blaster does in
Richard the third place for him to
buckle in consider how much harm is done
by vain and ignorant little people who
have hold up one idea or even something
less than I an idea ideas are actually
rather rare these days we're full of
ideology but not ideas lest an idea of
slogans a prompting of the appetite and
they will reduce to rubble centuries of
tradition the tenants of the religious
faith into which they were born the
life-giving folkways of their countrymen
reason itself and it's kid brother known
as common sense give it all up reduce it
to rubble to enthroned this single idea
or more likely slogan or itch to be the
ruling principle of all human life that
is mad
the madman says my buddy GK Chesterton
is not the man who has lost his reason
but who has lost everything but his
reason and I think what he means by it
is this the madman is seized by a fixed
idea or what we might say now a fixed
appetite he is no longer capable of that
happy accident when you tumble
back into common sense by a love for the
sweet and ordinary and permanent things
of human life do not let this happen to
you that is what I come types inscribe
on when I sign the covers of translation
of the inferno dear so-and-so do not let
this happen to you anybody here from New
Jersey you know the state model of New
Jersey comes from Dante la Shot dunya is
spread on some we confront a we can
abandon all hope ye who enter here you
see it as you cross the Delaware River
and rotate welcome to New Jersey the
gardens abandoned yeah yeah as you go
down into the eternal Meadowlands might
I just tell an anecdote here my uncle
used to work for the New Jersey State
Mosquito Commission when I was a little
boy I had no idea why they wanted more
mosquitoes in New Jersey do not let this
happen to you do not give to a mere idea
the love that you owe to reality and the
reverence that you owe to God and my
attention returns to the mockingbirds I
did not bring them up as a matter of
poetic or oratorical convention I have
heard that mr. mockingbird during the
spring mating season will lose a quarter
of his weight in a single day from the
strenuousness of his singing to mark out
his territory and impress miss
mockingbird
his fiancee you know that it's also said
that he can imitate more than a hundred
sounds from the calls of birds blue jays
Robins son - sirens creaking doors and
the warning beeps of trucks backing up
he is not a pajama bird his work on the
fence post is for the Haven of the nest
for those frail and precious eggs that
will break forth into new life now shall
man
whose thoughts can touch upon not a
hundred things but upon all things in
existence and even those creatures of
his imagination that do not exist and
never shall exist shall man be though
less than the mockingbird by
surrendering his mind and heart to the
tyranny of one idea or more likely one
slogan one itch one that inevitably
brings not new life but sterility
confusion and death of the mysterious
experience
mr. and mrs. mockingbird half of what
isn't in man called love I dare not
speak but shall man be the less than the
Mockingbird forgetting that he has been
made for love and if we accept as truth
the testimony st. John made by the God
who himself is love now we should not be
less there are two things you need to
know about the world my dear Gracchus I
will tell you them now because nobody
else will tell anybody them on this day
from Fairbanks to Miami the world is old
and the world is stupid I don't mean to
insult the world by saying so the world
is old and stupid it will always be old
and stupid and we are all fools too and
we grow old with every passing moment
now you can help to replace a bad law
with a good law you can take a wrecking
ball to an old school and you ought to
and build a good school indeed I'm
myself somewhat in the midst of that
ladder enterprise but if by changing the
world you mean that you are going to
make it something other than old and
stupid then you are more than the fool
that you were born to be as King Lear
fears from the fool eyeline other titles
that was given away that one that was
born with well you're more than the
ordinary natural fool you're a damn fool
and if you take the moral tone of more
careful commencement speakers if you say
first you have to change yourself then
only you can change
the world if by changing yourself you
mean that you can save yourself then
you're more than a damn fool you're
taking your direction from Satan the
first being who changed himself by
falling from himself believing that in
himself lay the capacity to be more than
he was created to be in himself lay the
capacity to be God Whitaker chambers
said of communism and the words ring
true today as true as ever that the
communism was not this or that economic
system or this or that the belief about
the arc of history communism was the
second oldest faith of man and it was
simply this you shall be as gods and
that applies now changing the terms of
the equation it applies now as well as
ever beg instead for the grace of God
that you may be changed by that grace is
a change that man rarely finds
comfortable which explains why he so
rarely prays for it then you will know
how little of the world will ever bear
your impress or deserves to bear it
everything that in me is most fully mine
alone is most worthy to be cast aside
with the scraps turn instead from
unreality to reality the mockingbird is
real and so are human beings when they
do things whose goodness and rightness
never passes away I'm going to give you
the words of CS Lewis in the weight of
glory he puts it as well as anybody
possibly can I think as long as we are
thinking of natural values he said we
must say that the Sun looked down on
nothing half so good as a household
laughing together over a meal or two
friends talking over a pint of beer or a
man alone reading a book that interests
him and they're all economies politics
laws armies and institutions save
insofar as they prolong and multiply
such scenes and I gather that you've had
plenty of such scenes here at Hillsdale
College all those institutions if they
do not multiply and prolong these are a
mere plowing the sand sowing the ocean a
meaningless vanity and vexation
the spirit the Sabbath is not a vigil
for Monday you don't have a family as an
accessory to your work or your
self-indulgent play there are people who
put kisses out to use I will not sully
the day by uttering their names do not
be so remember the true order of things
the good things I see then in my mind's
eye the lives of real people who
remember that order whom the
mockingbirds would understand if they
could understand anything they are not
angels they are not saints they do not
dwell in heaven they are men and women
on this wayside place of wonder this
earth they marry and are given in
marriage they raise a brood of shouting
and running children they tend the
business of the day which has joy enough
and trouble enough of its own they sing
they read books they grow vegetables
they argue with their cousins they bend
the knee in prayer they do not follow
madmen over the brink into the sea they
are not lemmings of tomorrow they like
the cliffs in the sea too well for that
they remember those who taught them not
because they gave them the key to all
knowledge but because they their
teachers were less foolish than the rest
Oh still foolish and because they were
human and they cherished them they do
not wish to impose their mad dreams upon
the world although many will be called
to defend the goodness of that world nor
do they despise the world
but in love they accept it for what it
is they do not require it to give what
it cannot give such people my dear
graduates I call them obedient servants
of the day they do not quench the flames
of love and wisdom nor do they hide
their light under a bushel they put it
on a lamp stand for all to see the same
lamp stand in whose light they are
reading a book or chatting about
children and then I imagine someone who
is more mischievous than the rest of
these who knows that all the world about
and I need the false world the world had
changed for changes sake the world
bustle the world it forgets what human
beings are for the world of the fixed
lust is like an endless plane of dead
grass and dried thorny bigots and he
sees the light on the lampstand the fire
of what is good and holy and sweet and
ordinary because everything is in order
he sees the light on the lampstand
and that fire and he sees that stubble
then oh what a baptism there shall be
and that you may be a part of that
baptism by fire whatever part you may
play I pray and good students may God be
with you
thank
[Applause]
Boylan forgot what he's supposed to do
aren't you supposed to help me give him
a degree yet yes good he's ready all
right professor esslyn thank you for
that wonderful thing and also funny I
had a feeling it would be and that I'm
personally I'm proud to have him here
today all of us are and would you come
forward please on behalf of the faculty
and the board of trustees of Hillsdale
College it is my privilege to present to
you Anthony Esalen the honorary degree
Doctor of Humane Letters
[Applause]